he ain't [ __ ] with me he listens to
everything
lebron james has like the most like
eclectic taste in rap music it'll be
like future one day and the next day
it's like [ __ ] a griselda album cut
you feel me yeah it's like
it's just kidding he's playing his case
playlist probably do you think it's his
you think he's a kid i don't think his
kid's listening to benny the butcher i'm
about to say i'm 34 bro relax
you that young kid i'm 34. i thought she
was super seasoned how old do you think
i am bro i thought she was like his
oldest taco bell
you be hanging with some old [ __ ] bro
who do i hang with this old besides him
he's really old that's one of my best
friends he's an old man
but who do i hang out with that's old i
think i just think when i think of when
i think of you i think of like old
people i just like almost like a
generation before me and rap i'm like
you think you think like oh look that's
he's like he's like a quasi-rosenberg
over here on the west coast
just the old rap guy maybe yeah listen i
wouldn't say i'm like i'm how old are
you thirty-three
thirty okay because i i was trying to do
the math from the t-pain thing you said
just older you're just a little bit
older than me i'm saying but you know
you seasoned bruh so are you but you've
been doing this for way longer than me
yeah i haven't been doing this since i
was like 17. i don't say you look old
thank you well i appreciate the uh i
thought she was a young looking old dude
now you're an old looking young dude
i'm not sure i've ever felt more
attacked on my show
and i don't know if i'm supposed to take
this as a good or a bad thing
he's like i thought you were a young
liquor no dude now you're an old looking
young dude
listen it is what it is man you know i'm
not the only one no
yeah